en ce début d'après midi à saint cyr sur
loire les automobilistes venus se servir
en essence sont sereins il ya au chant
qui est fermée jusqu'à 15 heures je
crois que ça ouvre à 15 heures donc là
c'est sur ma route ans que je fais le
plein de la voiture faut pas tomber dans
le dans le nom dans le coma dans le
négatif malgré un petit mouvement de
panique ce matin où le nombre de clients
a triplé dans cette station essence les
situations retrouvé son calme malgré
quelques points de distribution tombé à
sec notamment à cause du pont de mais la
grande majorité des exploitants de
stations essence ont pu faire face à la
demande
tout le monde a pris les devants comme
l'année dernière parce que l'année
dernière à la même date
on a eu exactement la même chose sauf
que c'était cette année c'est un peu
moins brutale nous avons quand même a pu
à voir les stocks qu'il fallait notre
notre pétrolier n'est pas trop inquiet
même s'ils gèrent assez étroitement la
sphère du côté des deux dépôts de
pétrole de saint pierre des corps
rien à signaler si ce n'est un calme
plat les deux centres ont continué à
approvisionner les stations d'essence
tourangelle est limitrophe la cgt
nationale des transporteurs routiers
avaient promis d'étendre la contestation
à l'ensemble du territoire
force est de constater qu'il n'ait pas
eu d'émulation dans le département par
ailleurs la raffinerie de donges en
loire-atlantique qui alimente le
département n'est plus à ce jour bloqués
en touraine pas de pénurie d'essence en
vue à ce jour